the friendly brand is something that
helps people to identify events places
activities in the info chemical city
region that friendly for families to go
to and when we say family's been
families of all ages it's not just
toddlers and children its youth it's the
appearance its grandparents family of
the whole far no consume everything
centered towards them we had in the
early 2000s mark blum see come down and
conduct a study on what our point of
difference was for Invercargill and
handers staff literally worked with
thousands of people and they all came
out with the same thing the best thing
about living in the south is it's a
great place to be a kid and to raise a
family and that's the best thing about
Invercargill so we unashamedly want to
play off that we are family friendly for
the members of the public if they
recognize what the friendly brand is and
and they see that logo next to something
that they may be interested in it gives
them that peace of mind it says okay the
people that have organized this event
the people that are running this
business these activities are going to
be good for me it helps the
decision-making process a lot easier and
if people are new to town they might not
necessarily have the knowledge of
history that South unders who've lived
in a mechanical for a long time if they
they don't necessarily know where to go
so it's a great way to welcome the new
families as well for a business to take
on the friendly brand it really shows
that they care as a as a parent with
young children when you're going
somewhere you want to know that there
are a nice wide aisles if you've got
somewhere that you need to push a pram
you need to know that they're going to
be good toilet facilities because kids
need to go to the toilet also knowing
that perhaps is somewhere where you can
change a baby that's really handy if
it's a place that has food for sale
knowing that there are healthy options
available as well when you're going out
with kids is nothing wrong with having a
treat and you know some deep fried
chicken nuggets might be quite
appropriate but for some people that's
not necessarily the option they're
looking for so you know
how are you going to treat your
customers when they come and I you
saying come to us and do business with
your children or we will look after your
children it really says a lot about
those those venues as social
participants in the city if somebody's
interested in becoming accredited with
the friendly Bransom to get in touch
with the community development section
at the end of chemical city council
they'll go through the requirements and
the requirements can be tailored we
really do look quite closely at what it
is that your business or event is trying
to achieve and and how we can work with
you to make sure that that it is
friendly to families